je suis henri de raincourt bon le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le pôle ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères et concerne également le mali
je sais que monsieur fabius n'est pas
parce qu'en ce moment même il est en
train d'accueillir à l'occasion de ce
retour sur le sur le sol national
notre compatriote madame florence cassez
et comme chacun ici je mesure les
sentiments qu'elle doit éprouver en cet
instant où elle retrouve la mère patrie
et tous nous sommes heureux très heureux
de voir que ces années de souffrance et
de martyrs aujourd'hui sont derrière
elle et donc il est tout à fait normal
que le ministre des affaires étrangères
soit à l'aéroport pour l'accueillir
alors ma question s'adresse au ministre
des affaires européennes et ça tombe
d'ailleurs aussi très bien compte tenu
de la nature de ma question qui prolonge
parfaitement ce que vient de dire à
l'instant le premier ministre je veux
rappeler quand même que le président de
la république à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse tenue le 13
novembre dernier avait indiqué qu'en
aucun cas la france n'interviendrait
elle-même au mali et devant la tournure
des événements comme cela vient d'être
rappelée à l'appel des autorités
fusse-t-elle provisoire de ce pays dans
le respect absolu des décisions du
conseil de sécurité le président de la
république a pris la sage et responsable
décision d'engager la france directement
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme le 11
janvier
vous savez que nous avons approuvé cette
décision du président de la république
nous soutenons cette action des pouvoirs
publics du gouvernement de nos soldats à
qui nous aussi nous voulons
naturellement rendre hommage alors
monsieur le ministre lors de vos
échanges avec les partenaires européens
vos homologues ont salué de façon
unanime l'action de la france
et c'est très bien lorsque j'entends
madame ashton dire l'union européenne va
jouer un rôle clé est actif dans les
semaines à venir
c'est positif mais nous voudrions des
choses concrètes qu'ils aillent excusez
moi monsieur le premier ministre
un peu au delà des actions de formation
dans lesquels l'europe est engagée
l'europe a élaboré la stratégie pour le
sel pour le développement du sahel et
nous avons un immense besoin dans cette
bataille très difficile à livrer contre
le terrorisme de l'europe de l'union
européenne n'ont pas pays par pays
mais globalement alors monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le ministre
des affaires européennes pouvez vous
nous dire aujourd'hui quelles sont les
efforts qui sont engagées par le
gouvernement français et quelles sont
les perspectives en matière
d'affirmation de la présence de l'union
européenne d'une manière claire et
précise dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
merci monsieur bernard cazeau 9 ministre
chargé des affaires européennes
monsieur sénateurs merci beaucoup pour
votre question kit l'occasion de
préciser quel est le rôle de l'union
européenne dans la crise du mali et de
préciser aussi les conditions dans
lesquelles notre pays a été amenée avec
ses partenaires de l'union européenne à
définir pour le mali une stratégie qui
permet à ce pays de retrouver son
intégrité territoriale de faire face aux
risques terroristes et par de l'alma il
s'agissait de sécuriser le continent
afrique a lui-même qui risque et en cas
de contamination théorise se trouver
déstabilisés est assuré aussi la
sécurité de l'europe et de notre propre
pays le premier point sur lequel je
voudrais insister comme l'a fait le
premier ministre à l'instant c'est sur
le rôle qu'a joué l'union européenne
dans la préparation de la formation des
troupes maliennes afin que celle ci
puisse permettre au mali de retrouver
son intégrité territoriale
vous avez eu raison d'insister monsieur
le sénateur sur le fait que l'ensemble
des événements qui se sont produits le
mali sont intervenus dans le strict
cadre de la légalité internationale et
ce fut d'ailleurs là la première action
concrète de lyon
il n'y aurait pas eu la prise des
résolutions 20 56 20 71 20 85 qui ont
défini le cadre légal dans lequel nous
sommes intervenus s'il n'y avait pas eu
de la part de l'union européenne au sein
des nations unies
une intervention conjointe convergent de
tous ces pays qui permettait la
définition de ce cadre international
deuxièmement nous avons souhaité que
tous les pays de l'union européenne
puissent définir ensemble les modalités
d'une formation des troupes maliennes de
l'armée malienne pour permettre à
celle-ci d'assurer la sécurité sur le
territoire du mali et pour permettre
aussi comme l'indiqué monsieur le
premier ministre à la misma de pouvoir
avec des troupes en nombre
assurer durablement la sécurité du mali
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
avec les pays de l'union européenne à
travers la mise en place d'un dispositif
de formation intitulé i outils m décidé
de mobiliser près de 500 militaires
venus de toute l'europe pour assurer la
formation et par ailleurs nous avons
également indiqué que nous étions à la
disposition de la cedeao pour assurer
aux côtés de la misma toute mission qui
permettait cette formation si au moment
où les terroristes ont décidé de faire
mouvement
la france n'avait pas sous l'impulsion
du président de la république pris la
décision d'intervenir tout ce que nous
avons décidé avec les européens ne
serait pas possible aujourd'hui le mali
serait tombé entre les mains des
terroristes est aujourd'hui la situation
serait celle d'une déstabilisation
majeure et nous avons par conséquent
continuer à travailler avec les
européens qui contrairement à ce que
nous avons pu entendre à certains
moments ont mobilisé des moyens à nos
côtés moyens aériens pour assurer du
transport de troupes et en nombre moyens
sanitaires pour venir en assistance
moyens humanitaires qui seront bien
nécessaire sur le terrain et par
ailleurs nous réunissons la conférence
des donateurs à abidjan à addis abeba le
29 pour mobiliser des moyens financiers
qui permettront d'aller au bout de cette
opération
nous sommes donc dans une action seront
mais elle est où la france joue un rôle
de précurseur pour rétablir l'intégrité
territoriale du mali et assurer la
sécurité du sahel face aux risques
terroristes